okay how's your brain going so far dad
all right now what I'm gonna do to
finish here is to show you a useful
shortcut I'm gonna put an asterisk next
to it which is that what I'm about to
show you is not obligatory it's not
compulsory you have to know how to do
polynomial long division but this
shortcut about to show you you do not
have to know it's not in this syllabus
but it's very useful okay so this
shortcut you can make a little
subheading is called synthetic division
it's not long division it's synthetic
division now my encouragement to you is
synthetic division is a shortcut it's
really good to know if you are hurting
for time you'll like at the end of an
exam you really have five minutes left
you have a couple of questions left and
one of them ends up being a polynomial
that you have to divide that 5 minutes
is going to get sucked up by this whole
process okay and you're like wait but I
have another thing that I have to need
to go onto okay that's when I would pull
out something like this or alternatively
you've got an ear - you're like I think
that's it you want to check it well
you've got another way to make sure that
you have the right answer
okay now synthetic division relies on
the fact that have a look at this long
division here or that long division over
there do you see a huge amount of it is
kind of wasted because the important
parts are the numbers do you agree like
the 0 and the 2 this negative to this
negative 4 those are the things are
actually operating on yes the X cubed
the X Squared's the X's they just kind
of sit in the background they're just
like place value right when I write a
thousand and five it would take me so
much longer if I had to literally write
out one thousand zero hundreds zero tens
and five units saying thousands hundreds
tens and units is kind of unnecessary
the numbers are really the important
thing yes so the first thing that
synthetic division does is it
doesn't write down all the X's it just
writes down the numbers so what I'm
going to do is think about the let's do
that first one again and I'll show you
because we can do a parallel here the
first one we did see this divisor yeah
I'm gonna write the 0 of this divisor
think about that I introduced this term
yesterday or the day before the zero of
this is a value of x that makes this
zero right so what value of x do I put
in here to make it zero near you two all
right they're done and then the next
thing is I'm gonna write down all of the
numbers the coefficients of my dividend
right look at the original question that
we did I think the first one was three
so three well tell me tell me there's
because I just rubbed it off which was
very minus 1/7 thank you
so these are the numbers these are the
things that really matter okay
in my mind I'm kind of remembering well
the last number was a constant right
it's always I mean if of zero it'll be
zero zero constant this is an X this is
an x squared this is an X cubed so when
I look at this it's implied that this is
a cubic or it stands for a number in a
cubic okay now I'm still about to do a
division but this is a different kind of
division so to distinguish a little bit
I'm trying to draw my division sign
upside down okay
just to make it look a little
so that's three there I'm pretty sure
that was the coefficient that I started
with right there see that I I didn't
have a rapport okay three negative one
seven negative four is that okay yep so
I have to write down every single one
obviously this is frequently a 1 but
doesn't have to be one okay
all right I'm going to do something else
weird I'm going to put another line down
here just the structure my working as
you'll see in a minute
this line here is roughly equivalent to
all of these lines that you've drawn in
there we don't need to draw them for
synthetic division okay and now the
actual algorithm begins so I'm going to
show it to you once and I'm going to go
through it and then I'm going to ask you
to do the game for me and you're gonna
have to walk me through ok so the first
thing is I need new color see that
leading coefficient there and a 3 I'm
just gonna write it down I'm just gonna
write down like directly I don't have to
do any working with it just gonna write
down 2 3 ok
and then here you know how with long
division there's a process that kind of
loops around and around and around and
around
ok I'm going to show you the process
that loops here okay
it's very similar to this one but ever
so slightly different to make things a
bit easier for your brain okay here are
the steps see this number I'm gonna
multiply you know multiply that gives me
negative 6
I'm gonna write that underneath the next
column because of course I got to go
through the X Squared's the X's in the
cluster I multiplied now I'm gonna add
you care with that
just add it down the column okay so I
multiplied to get this and then I added
to get that and now I rinse and repeat
I'm gonna multiply and then I'm gonna
add ok with that
one last time I'm gonna multiply and
then I'm going to add
hmm so before I interpret this because
this is the answer you finished did you
see how this is a shortcut right the
first thing I did was I just wrote down
the leading coefficient just straight
down that working required but once I've
got that there my loop is that I
multiply and add multiply and add
multiply and add okay now it requires a
bit of thinking to interpret this thing
right you are dividing a cubic degree
three by a linear divisor degree 1 so
your answer ought to be of degree 2
right
so therefore if this is degree 2 and
that's the leading term this is 3 X to
the power of 2 there's the next term
there's the next term what do you think
the final number is it's the remainder
that was quick right I even actually
explained it to you I was talking
through it and it was still faster
dramatically faster okay so if you have
a look carefully have a look at these
numbers here see these numbers that
we've written down do you notice that
every single one of those numbers is in
your original working right do you
recognize the negative 7 the 14 the
negative 46 they're all there it's the
same thing we're doing the same thing
okay why is this faster and not just
faster it's less error-prone two reasons
number one we didn't write all of the
X's which is part like that takes half
the time right and all of the space as
well okay that's the first thing the
second thing is when I get this what do
I do with it to get to the next line
from here to here what do I do
I subtract generally I have to do
subtraction all the way
okay now subtraction is problematic for
two reasons number one our brains aren't
as good at subtraction right we're good
at it these together you put things into
a pile how many are there right not only
are we better at addition generally
speaking we don't have to deal with
double negatives when you add because
you're never subtracting a negative
you're adding negatives do you see that
negative 1 plus 96 it's negative 7 ok
how come I'm adding rather than
subtracting because that's kind of
opposite
so see this guy at the front that's the
other thing to take it over right this
guy here is the zero of the divisor okay
so since what I did right at the get-go
is I actually turn this whole thing
upside down right instead of going X
plus 2 I'm thinking about negative 2
that changes the sign of everything
right so that's why I'm adding rather
than subtracting okay now I really like
this method because it is faster and is
less error-prone in addition to that see
how over here you're like oh gross side
divided by a quadratic I wasn't kidding
95% of the time you're dividing by
something linear okay so because this
process is basically geared towards that
that's why you just like that 3 how did
I find out that it was 3 down there well
if you always divide by a monic linear
thing then this will always just be
you're dividing by 1 that's what you're
doing ok so let's see if you know how to
do this let's come up with a new
polynomial and you're going to talk me
through it ah yes order yeah because
you're not writing the exes strain the
coefficients okay let's actually do you
guys have your laptop's there yeah let's
pick a question monic linear factors
which is 95% of the kinds of questions
again you can't piss not with it you can
but it's not with ok here we go
I'm pulling this out of 4 see it's
question to Part D question to Part D so
this is what we get to execute
is anyone there so they can reach me yep
and I'm foresee what's the next it's a
15 okay and what's our divisor okay so
what do I write I'll give you a start
here's this is the big upside-down
division side right what's the very
first number I need to put okay it's the
zero this guy which is three what goes
on the right-hand side okay there's my
first coefficient good
don't forget the neat your side okay
good fantastic
underneath my big division side what do
I put another line okay yeah and now I
get to just bring down the leading
coefficient and now it's my repeating
step here comes my cycle okay tell me
what's all right okay so that gives me
sikhs yeah and good go again add go
again last one
how's that you see how much quicker that
was it's just you know it just takes all
the extraneous stuff okay that's what it
answer that's what we're going to use
we're going to interpret that to come up
with an answer you divided a cubic by
linear so what do you expect the answer
to be this is a quadratic right so this
is the x squared term this is the X term
and this is your constant which there's
one last number as the remainder done
Spees okay so let me mention again if
you find this you'd like my brain is too
full just mastering
like long division okay if you have to
make a hard call this is the one you
have to learn okay and people often look
at this and they're like what even is
this like I don't know what it means
okay
including sometimes markers they'll look
at this image okay however if you're
hurting for time you can answer this
question twice as fast as you can with
this you just have to write this thing
out right so if you're hurting for time
to do it if you're checking an answer do
it if you're an extension to student and
you're like I've got something else to
worry about in this question this is
just like the warmup okay then do it
because you have like seven other marks
in this question you need to really
worry about so just get this out of the
way and get over with it okay